so welcome everybody welcome back
uh let's get started with today's
lecture
we
um
where were we
on tuesday
we
covered
uh the main topic was the recursion
theorem
which allows
programs to self-reference
and we saw some applications of that
too so
we gave a new proof that atm is
undecidable
we looked at this language of minimal
turing machine descriptions
and we had a short digression into
mathematical logic where we looked at
how one shows that there are true but
unprovable
statements in any uh reasonable formal
system
okay so today we're i'm gonna shift
gears entirely um and we're moving into
the second half of the course uh
where we are beginning a study of
uh computational complexity theory
and uh we'll
say a little bit about that during the
course of the lecture
um of course but um you know the main
things that we're going to cover
in terms of content that you will need
um is defining the
complexity classes and the class p
um so and we'll prove a few theorems
along the way but that's the main
objective of today's lecture
computability theory which was the
subject of the first half of the course
and which is what going what the midterm
exam is going to cover
um
was a subject that was an active area of
of mathematical uh study
in the first part of the 20th century i
really got
it really dates back um into the late
19th century in fact where people were
trying to figure out how to formalize
mathematical reasoning um
[Music]
but that really really got going um in
the 1930s with the work of girdle and
church and turing um
who um
really formalized for the first time
what we mean by algorithm and that that
allowed the study of algorithms to
really get started um with and it had
its impact as i mentioned on the actual
uh design building and thinking about
real computers
um
[Music]
the main question if you kind of boil
the subject down to a a single question
is is some language decidable or not
um
in complexity theory which got started
kind of
when uh computability theory more or
less wrapped up as a subject largely
because they answered many of the
questions that they they answered pretty
much all of the questions that they were
asking so there really aren't uh
interesting unsolved questions left in
that field
and you really need mathematical
questions to keep a subject alive
unsolvable questions so complexity
theory got its start in the 1960s and it
continues on as an activator area of
research to the present day
um
and i guess if you could boil it down it
would be is is a language decidable
with some restriction on the resources
such as the amount of time or memory or
some other or some other kinds of
resources that you might provide you
know randomness and so on although those
are followed within the area of
computational complexity theory
so let's get ourselves started with an
example
here is a language that we've looked at
in the past
a to the k b to the k
and um let's look at it from now from
the perspective of complexity
all of the languages that we're going to
be studying in complexity are all going
to be decidable languages um so the
question of undecidability
undecidability in complexity theory is
not really of interest it's all
decidable languages but the question is
how decidable
you know what sort of resources do you
need to do the deciding
um
so
um for this language a how many steps
are needed
well we're going to spend a little time
just kind of
setting up
the definitions of the subject um and
and motivating them so in the in this
for this language a when i ask how many
steps are needed well it's going to
depend upon which input you have in mind
you know some inputs might require more
steps than others
so the way we're going to set the
subject up which is the the the standard
way that uh people in this field look at
it um and i think you know that applies
to you know
lots of
examples outside as well
um is that we're going to kind of group
all of the inputs of the same length
together
and look at the maximum
uh
uh cost the maximum number of steps you
need to solve any one of those inputs of
a given length and we'll do that for
each length
and the way we're going to frame it is
in terms of giving a maximum or what's
called an upper bound
on
the amount of time that you need
uh to solve all of those inputs of
length n
that's what's uh sometimes called worst
case complexity i'm sure many of you
seen this already but just to make sure
we're all together on this
um uh you might contrast that for
example with what's called average case
complexity where instead of looking at
the most difficult case among all
inputs of length n you take the average
of all inputs of length n and then you
have to then it's a little bit more
complicated because then you need to
have a probability distribution on those
inputs and so on we're not going to look
at it in this course from that
perspective we're only going to be
looking at what's called worst case
complexity
um
so let's um
begin then uh uh by taking uh looking at
this in more detail and uh
taking as our
starting point the theorem that says
that on a one tape turing machine
which is deciding this language a
you know a to the k b to the k
um you can do this on a one tape turing
machine um
m we're calling it
in at most
some constant times n squared steps
for any input of length n
where
the constant is going to be fixed
independent of it
okay
so
this is going to be
you know
having a constant in in in in
factor in the complexity is going to
come all come up often and so instead of
saying this over and over again we're
going to use the notation um
that
m uses order in squared steps um i'm
sure many of you seen that terminology
as well but just just for the purposes
of making sure we're all together on
that there is this big o and little o
notation i'm expecting i'm expecting you
to be familiar with that
big o is when you apply applied to
functions as it's done
you say uh f is big o of g as
for two functions f and g
it's basically if f is less than or
equal to g
if you're ignoring constant factors
and you say f is little o of g
if f is strictly less than g if you're
ignoring constant factors that's kind of
one sort of informal way of looking at
it the precise definition is given up
there on the slide and if you haven't
seen it before make sure you look at it
in the book where it's all carefully
described and defined
so that you're comfortable with these
notions because it's really we're going
to be using this without any further
discussion uh from here on
okay
so let's get to the proof then of this
theorem that you can do uh the language
a in order n squared steps
not super hard if i think if i ask you
to come up with an algorithm to solve a
this would be the algorithm that you
would find basically
first you would start off by scanning
the input
w to make sure it's of the right form
so a run of a's followed by a run of b's
of some lengths
um and if it's not of that form
uh then you're going to reject right
away
the next thing you'll do is then go
through a repeat loop
um in the turing machine
and you know if you imagine here is your
machine here is the input w you're going
to go through that repeating repeatedly
of course you can do this in a number of
different ways but here's the way i i'm
i have in mind for you uh on this slide
anyway
we're going to scan the entire tape
crossing off one
a single a and a single b
um on a
on a scan
and then you're going to keep doing that
until you've crossed off everything
um
unless you run out of a's or you run out
of b's
in that case you're going to reject
um
if you run out of a's or b's before you
run out of uh the other type
then you know that you started out with
an unequal number and so the machine is
going to reject
if you've managed to cross them all off
without running out of one before the
other then you'll accept
i know this is kind of obvious but i
think it's important to get us all
together on this at the beginning
so here's a little um animation of the
turing machine doing that
i'm not showing the motion of the head
but imagine the head scanning back and
forth crossing off these a's and b's
one a and one b on each pass
until they're all crossed off and then
it accepts
unless of course it runs out of a's or
b's before the other type then it
rejects
okay
now let's do a very quick informal
analysis of how much time this has taken
so the very first stage i'm calling each
of these things stages of the turing
machine to distinct
distinguish them from the steps of the
turing machine which the individual
transition function moves
so this is the entire stage of the
machine
the very first stage takes order n steps
because you have to make a scan across
the input
and then you know i'm not giving all the
full detail of course you're going to
scan and then you're going to return the
head back to its starting position i'm
not that's just going to be an extra
factor of n an extra an extra
an extra n
um so that's what we're talking about
being order n steps for the very first
stage um
and then as you do through goes with the
repeat loop each time you go through the
repeat loop you're gonna cross off
one a and one b
so
um that's gonna mean you're gonna have
to do this roughly order you're gonna
have to do this order n times in order
to cross off all the a's and b's
so there's gonna be edit order and
iterations of this repeat loop
each one of them is going to again
require a state a scan so that's order n
steps uh for each one of the iterations
um so adding that all up
um
the very top row gives us the order n
and then we have the order and
iterations times order n steps is order
n squared steps
and so the sum of these two is order n
square order n squared steps
due to the nature of arithmetic when you
have the big o notation
the dominant term
overrides all of the others
so
that's
in a nutshell
how we well this is our very first
example of analyzing the turing machine
algorithm
for a language okay so let me
ask you now whether there is some other
turing machine some other one tape
turing machine which can do better
than this turing machine um does in
terms of how much time it takes
so one idea that you might have
instead of crossing off a single a or in
the single b maybe you can cross off um
two a's and two b's or ten a's and ten
b's well that'll cut down the running
time by a factor of ten
but from the standpoint of this theorem
it's still going to be an order n
squared algorithm
um and so that's not gonna that really
doesn't change
um
the amount of time used from from the
perspective of um from our perspective
where we're going to be ignoring the
constant factors on the running time
um
so i ask you here can you do better than
just improving things by a constant
factor
there we go
okay
so here's a check-in on this on this uh
on this problem on the problem a solving
deciding a on a one tape turing machine
can we do better
than
uh order n squared as i just described
in that uh
in that
theorem and that algorithm for that
theorem or um you know can you get it
down to n log n
um or maybe you can get it down to order
n
um what do you think
uh obviously you know we're
we're just getting started but
just um just make your best guess
and let me just post that for you as a
poll
what's most important to me is that you
understand
the terminology that we're using and the
way we're discussing with the way we're
talking about it because that's going to
be setting setting us up for the
definitions that we're going to come a
little bit later in the lecture
okay
so um i'm going to close the poll
um uh we're kind of all over the place
on it but that's that's that that's good
um
uh
since we haven't really covered this
material yet material yet
in fact b is the correct answer we can
improve this algorithm down to order n
log n
but not all the way down to order n um
so let me get let me show you how you do
it in order n log n on the next slide
and
so here
is a one tape turing machine that can
decide a by using
only order and log n steps
instead of order and squared steps so
this is a significant improvement um
so
i'm just i'll describe the turing
machine here again is the picture of the
machine on an input um
and the very first thing i need to say
is that we're going to scan to make sure
the input is of the right form
and now we're going to again it's going
to be
making repeated passes over the input
but we're going to do it a little
differently now
instead of crossing off a single a and a
single b or some fixed number of a's and
a fixed number of b's we're going to
cross off every other a
and every other b
in in that way we're going to
essentially cut the number of a's and
b's in half
and that's why the number of iterations
is only going to be a log instead of um
linear
okay so we're going to cross off every
other a and every other b
um
and at the same time we're going to keep
track
of the parity the even-odd parity of the
number of a's
um that we've seen and the s and the
parity of the number of b's that we've
seen um that have not yet been crossed
off
um and we're going to compare those
parodies to make sure that they agree
if they ever disagree
we know we started off with different
numbers of a's and b's
um
and i'll i'll illustrate this in a
second just to make sure you where um
we understand this algorithm
okay so
i'm going to write down as a little
table of the parities that we've seen
and i'm going to illustrate the
algorithm with a little animation
okay so again we're now going to
scan across crossing off every other a
and then every other b
but now but before we get to the b's we
observe as we cross these off that we
had six a's now i'm not saying we count
them we just keep track of the even odd
parity that can be done in the finite
control of the machine
counting them would be more complicated
but karen but just keeping track of the
parity is not is is something that the
finite automaton could do
so the parity in this case because they
were six is going to be even
now we cross off the b's
same even parity now we're going to
return the head back to the beginning
i'm obviously not showing the head
moving here we return the head back to
the big beginning and now we scan across
again crossing off every other remaining
a and counting the parity of the
remaining a's
so here now
it's going to be this one and this one
are going to get crossed off
and there were three a's so that was odd
parity
and the same for the b's
three b's odd parity
and now we return our head back to the
beginning
cross again off uh every other a and
every other b
every a
so that was odd parry there was just one
crossing off the b
odd parity because it's just one they
all agree
um so the machine is going to accept
um because everything is now crossed off
and and the parity is agreed along the
way
let me just say for a second you know
obviously if you ever get disagreement
on the parities then you know that the
two uh
the number of a's and number b's had to
disagree
um
but how do we know that if the parities
always agree that we actually did start
out with the same number of a's as b's
and that you could see that in a number
of different ways but perhaps you know
uh a cute way to see it
is there is actually if you look at
these parodies here the sequence of
parodies actually in reverse
so if you let's say odd odd even um and
you look at the binary representation of
the number of a's which is six so the
binary representation would be one one
zero
the fact that you get odd odd even and
one one zero
is not a coincidence in fact the
sequence of parodies in reverse that you
get
is um
exactly
um the same as the binary representation
you'd have to
you know confirm that with a little
proof it's not hard uh but um that once
you've confirmed that you can see that
um if the
sequence of parities agree then the
numbers have to be the same because the
binary uh representations agreed
okay so now getting to the analysis here
again order n steps to do the check
login iterations
each scan takes order n steps
so the total uh running time here is
going to be order n log n
because it's going to be the log n times
n that's where the log n log n comes
from
now questions you might ask could i do
even better than that can i beat
n log n by more than any constant factor
um so can i do little o
of n log n
um and the answer is no
this is the best possible
a one tape turing machine for this
language um
uh so a one day turing machine cannot
decide a by using little o
of n log n steps
we're not going to prove that
i'm not going to ask you to be
responsible for the proof but in fact um
what you can show is that any language
that you can do on a one tape turing
machine in little o of n log n steps
turns out to be regular
okay so um uh you can prove a rather
strong theorem here not super difficult
to to prove but i don't want to spend a
lot of time on
um
uh proving bounds for turing machines
because you know really the whole
purpose of setting this up using turing
machines is to talk about algorithms in
general algorithms in general i'm not
going to be focusing on the nitty gritty
of turing machines
um
okay uh so um
what is
my um
okay yeah so i wanted to just stop and
make sure that we were
we are together here um so
a brief pause and feel free to send me
any questions
um
okay this is a good question if we can
keep track of parodies why can't we just
keep track of the number of a's or b's
um
well you could keep track of the parity
in the finite memory and so you can do
that with effectively no work
but the finite memory cannot is not
enough for doing an account up to you
know some arbitrarily large number
now you could store the count on the
tape
but that's going to cost you time to
maintain that counter
and so um
that's not going to be
so
simple
as keeping track of the parity
in the finite memory
um
okay
somebody's asking if a star b star is
regular yes a star b star is regular so
what
um but a to the k b to the k which is
our language is not regular uh right so
that's the language we're looking at
um
okay
so
getting questions about what happens
with multiple tapes we'll talk about
that in a second um
yes we could do an order end steps on a
regular computer sure but uh
you know
right for this slide anyway we're
looking at one tape turing machines um
okay getting questions about a big o and
little o um
for something to be little
little o means it's less than any
constant factor times the function um
so you have to look at the definition in
the book i think almost
enough people in the class probably know
this and have seen this already i don't
want to spend everybody's time on it but
uh please review it in the book
somebody's asking if you need to store
the parody on the tape no you can just
throw it in the finite memory um
uh
i mean storing the finite memory seems
to be the simplest thing
okay when we move on please feel free to
ask questions to the tas as well we have
two tas at least here attending uh with
me so
um
good
um
right um
all right so
we cannot do better than a one-tape
turing machine on a one-tape turing
machine and order n log n um and that's
something we can prove that we're not
going to do it here
however if you if you have if you change
the model
for example you use a two-tape turing
machine then yes as a lot of you are
suggesting in the chat you can do better
than that
so
if we now have a two-tape turing machine
or a multi-tape turing machine you can
do it in order n steps and that's
actually the point i i'm really trying
to make here um
so if you have here your um
two tape turing machine
um
then
two tips
same language
now what we're going to do is copy the
a's to the second tape
that we can do on a single pass
um and then once the a's have been
copied to the second tape we can
continue on reading the b's
and match them off with the a's that
appear on the second tape
so in order n steps you can do the
comparison instead of order n log n
steps
and of course if they match you're going
to accept otherwise reject
so let's just see here's a little
animation uh
uh uh
demonstrating that of course it's very
simple
um
so here is that here that if you could
see that it came maybe a little too fast
here let's just show it again here is
the heads moving across and the a is
coming down uh to the bottom
and now the head the upper head is going
to continue on reading the bees the
lower head is going to
go back to the beginning on the a's
and matching off the b's with the a's
and that's how we can verify or check
that they are the same number
okay so now in this case they were the
same number so the machine would accept
if they were the different number the
machine would not accept
um
and the analysis is very simple
um
uh each stage here is going to take a
linear number of steps order n steps
um because it just consists of a single
uh scan there are no uh there are no
loops in this machine
no no no repeat loops
um
okay
so
um
question on this
um
all right
why don't we move on then um
now observe
and the point i'm really trying to make
is that
uh
on a one type turing machine you can do
it in n log n but not any better but on
a two tape turning machine you can do it
in order n
um
so there's a difference
in how
much
time you need to spend how many steps
you need to spend depending upon the
model
and that's significant for us um
so the number of steps depends on the
model one tape turing machine was order
and login multitape was order n
we call them model dependence
if you contrast that with the situation
in the complexities in the computability
section of the course
we had model independence
the choice of the model didn't matter
and that was nice for us because
the theory of decidability didn't depend
upon whether you had a one tape turing
machine or a multi-tape turing machine
it was all the same
set of decidable and recognizable
languages
uh
so we didn't have to worry about which
model we're actually going to work with
we could work with any model even just
an informal model of algorithm
um was going to would be good enough
because we're going to end up
with the same
notion
in the end
now that's
goes away
in complexity theory
now we have
a difference depending upon the model
and from a mathematical standpoint
that's a little less nice
because
um you know which model do you work with
if you want to understand the complexity
of some problem you know that you have
at hand
um now you have to make a choice you're
going to work with the turing machine
around how many tapes or you're going to
look at some other model and you're
going to get different results so it's
somewhat less natural from a
mathematical standpoint just to talk
about the complexity of some problem
but we're going to kind of um
bring back something close enough to
model independence by observing that
even though we don't have uh model
independence as we did in computability
theory we can limit
how much dependence there is
so the amount of dependence is going to
be low
as we will see
provided you stick with a reasonable
class of deterministic models
so the dependence though it does exist
is not going to be um
that much it's going to be polynomial
dependence
and we'll say exactly what that means in
a second
um and from our standpoint that's going
to be uh um a small difference uh a
negligible difference that we're going
to ignore
um
so we're going to focus on questions
that do not depend on the model choice
among these reasonable deterministic
models
now you may say well that's not
interesting from a practical standpoint
because polynomial differences say the
difference between n squared and n cubed
certainly make a difference in practice
but
it really
uh depends
on the
um
the uh
um
you know what what kinds of questions
you're focusing in on so if you want to
look at something that's very uh
a very precise distinction say between
you know n squared and n cubed um then
you might want to focus in on
which model you want to be working with
and that's going to be more the domain
of an algorithms class
but from our standpoint we're going to
be looking at other still important
questions but there are questions that
um don't uh depend upon exactly which
polynomial you're going to have we're
going to be looking more at distinctions
between polynomial and exponential
and still there are important practical
questions that arise in in that
somewhat different um
setting
okay
so with that in mind
we're going to continue to use the one
tape turing machine as our basic model
of complexity um
since the the model um among the
reasonable deterministic models in the
end is not going to matter from the from
the perspective of the kinds of
questions we're going to be asking
um
okay
um
so
with that so
we are going to continue then it's
important to remember that from going
forward we're going to stick with the
one tape turing machine model maybe
that's something you would have expected
us to do anyway but i'm trying to
justify that you know through this
little discussion that we had so far
thus far
so now we're going to start defining
things
with the one tape model in mind
um
so so first of all if you have a turing
machine we're going to say it runs in a
certain amount of time
so if t is some sort of time bound
function like n squared or n log n
we'll say the machine runs in that
amount of time like n squared or n log n
if
that machine m
always halts within that number of steps
on all inputs of length n
so it always holds within t of n steps
on inputs of length n
then we'll say that the machine runs in
t of n time
so in other words if the machine runs in
n squared time
then the machine when you give it an
input of length 10 it's gotta it's got
to be guaranteed to hold within a
hundred steps
uh 10 10 squared 100 steps on every
input of length 10.
um that's what it means
um for the machine to be running in that
much time and it has to do that for
every every n for every input length
and with that we're going to come to the
following definition which is
highlighted in color because it's going
to be um
we're going to be using this definition
throughout the semester so it's
important to understand it
this is the definition of what's called
the time complexity classes
and what i'm going to do
is take some bound
t of n and again think of t of n like a
bound like n squared
so if you have time t of n or like time
n squared
that's going to be the collection of all
languages that you can decide
within time and square or within time t
of n
so in other words it's a collection of
all languages b
such that there's some
one tape turing machine here we're
focusing again on the one tape turning
machine there is some deterministic one
tape turing machine
that decides b
and that machine runs in that amount of
time
so this is a collection of languages
the time collect complexity class is a
set of languages i'm going to draw it
now as a diagram
um
so if you take the language again that
we've been
using as our standard example a to the
kb to the k
um
that's in time and log n as we observed
for uh uh
two slides two slides back or three
slides back
so on a one tape turning machine you can
do this language a in time n log n
so it's in the time complexity class n
log n this this
region here captures all of the
languages
that you can do
in order and log in time
for example
that also includes all of the regular
languages
why is that
well any regular language
can be done on a one tape turing machine
in time order n
because the turing machine only just
needs to scan across doesn't even need
to write just need to scan across from
left to right on the on the tape and in
n steps it has the answer
so all of the regular languages are
actually in time n certainly a subset of
time n log n and these all form a kind
of a hierarchy so if you increase the
bound you can imagine that the collect
class of languages grows
as you
allow the machine to have more and more
steps to do its computing
um so these are all the languages that
you can do in n squared
uh order n square time on a one tape
turing machine
and cube time on a one tape turing
machine and so on
to exponential time two to the end time
on a one tape turning machine these are
all collections of languages
um
getting larger and larger um as we
increase the bound um
so someone is asking kind of is
okay uh let's see let me let me get to
some of these questions here i'll try to
get them in order um
uh
okay um
so somebody says if you have a good
question if you have a regular computer
so an ordinary sort of random access
computer so we'll talk about that in a
second can do it in order and uh can you
do it on a multi-tape during machine
also in order and time actually i don't
know the answer teller offhand i suspect
the answer is no
that
ordinary computers have a random access
capability that turing machines do not
and so that there are going to be some
examples of problems that you can do
with a random with a regular computer
that you cannot do with a multi-tape
turing machine in order end time uh i'd
have to double check that though so
we can and so some question
what what we believe is true and what we
can prove to be true um as we'll see
there are a lot of things that we
believe to be true in this subject that
we don't know how to prove
um
somebody's asking kind of an interesting
sort of more advanced question is there
some function f
uh some some some some some function t
where um it's so big that it so that
time t of n gives you all of the
decidable problems
um
it would be a very big t but the the
answer actually to that question is yes
um but
that's a little bit exotic so let let's
not spend a lot of time on that right
here but i'm happy to talk about that
offline
um
it's a good question here somebody's
asking me does it mean that there are no
languages between order n and order n
log n because i pointed out that
anything below n log n is going to be
regular
and so as soon as you get below n log n
you can do it in order n and yes there
is what's called a gap
between order n and order n log n on a
one take turing machine this you don't
get anything new from order n until you
jump up so from order n to order n log
log n
nothing new shows up
um
so we'll talk about those kinds of
things a little a little bit down the
road when we look at actually the
relationship among these various uh
classes and what we call a hierarchy
theorem which shows you know what how
much bigger do you have to make the
bound in order in order to be sure
you'll get something new
um
all right
[Music]
okay somebody's asking is there a
model which has the same time complexity
as a normal computer
uh
well i mean there's the random access
model which is supposed to capture a
normal computer um
okay so
let me let me um
these are all great questions kind of
more
uh
riffing off of
this into in more into more advanced
directions
uh
let's move on um here's another check-in
um suppose we take this is a little bit
of a
check to see how well your how
comfortable you are with the notions
we've just presented and whether you can
think about some of the arguments that
we've made and apply them in into a new
language so take the language ww reverse
um
you know strings
followed by their
um
uh this followed by themselves backwards
this language via the even length
palindromes if you will
um what's the smallest
uh bound that you need
uh to be able to solve
uh
that language b
and i'll pose it as a
pose that is a question for you
so which which time complexity class
is
um
that language b in
is it time
order n or n log n n squared
so on what do you think
so we're about to come to the coffee
break so uh why don't we um
uh
i'll answer any questions that come up i
think we're
got everybody uh answered so i'm gonna
end the polling okay make sure you're in
if you want to be in
um
so
the correct answer is in fact uh order n
squared
um
you it would be hard for you know you
you know every
reasonable guess here would be order n
log n i mean you can come up with the
same procedure
that the as the one we showed at the
beginning uh the order n squared
procedure for eight to the kb to the k
works for ww reverse as well um you can
just cross off
sweep back and forth crossing off
um
the symbol from w
and going across to the other side
crossing off the symbol from w reverse
and that procedure will give you an n
squared an order n squared algorithm
um
you might imagine you can improve it to
order n log n but you cannot you can
prove that order n squared is the best
possible um
i
i'm a little unhappy that a lot of you
came up with order n frankly because i
already told you that order n is uh
these are just regular languages
anything that you can do in less than
little o of n log n is going to be
regular and we know this language is not
regular so this is a this was
uh
not a good answer
you know so
please pay attention
and um okay
so let us
stop sharing uh i will turn now to the
uh our our
our break
uh for five minutes
and i'm happy to you know try to take
questions along the way as we're um
uh we're waiting for the time to
to end so let's see let me
put this up here
okay
let me try to take some of your
questions
um
so someone has asked me about quantum
computers as reasonable models of
you know
you may say a quantum computer is a
reasonable model of computation
and that's fine i would not say it's a
reasonable model deterministic
computation um
uh at least from our standpoint though
let's not quibble about the words um
i'm not including quantum computers in
um the collection of
um machines that i have in mind right
now when i'm talking about the the the
reasonable models of deterministic
computation that we're going to be we're
going to be discussing
um
uh
let's see
okay a bunch of people apparently are
asking the tas
why all regular languages can be done in
order n
um
[Music]
so
if you
think about a dfa
which you know
processes
a
an input of length n
within steps
and the dfa is um
going to be a type of turing machine
that never writes on its tape
uh so if the dfa can do it in in in n
steps the turing machine can do it n
steps and so therefore every regular
language can be done in order and steps
on a turing machine um
not sure where the confusion is so
please
message me if you're not still not
getting it um
okay somebody's saying why are we using
one-take turing machines instead of
random access wouldn't it be better to
use the random access machines
um if you were using if you're trying to
do algorithms yes
that's a more reasonable model we're
trying to prove things about the
computation and from that standpoint we
want to use as simple as model as
possible
uh trying to prove things
um using random access computers it's
possible be very messy
so that's why we don't use uh random
access machines to prove the kinds of
things we're going to be proving
um about computation
you know that that are really the meat
and potatoes of this course
so uh
i mean there's
compelling reasons why you would want to
use a simple model like a turing machine
but not a
powerful model like a random access
computer
so somebody's asking me does
um
the class
the time uh order and log log n have any
elements yes it has all the regular
languages but nothing else order n log
log n is only read only the regular
languages you have to go all the way up
to or and log in before you get
something non-regular
uh somebody's asking me are we going to
talk about how the random access model
works no
you know there's uh beyond the scope of
this course
outside of what we're going to be doing
we're going to talk about turing
machines
not because we care so much about turing
machines but i'm trying to prove things
about computation and the turing
machines are a convenient vehicle for
doing that um
okay our candle has burned out uh why
don't we return then to um
the next uh slide so everybody come back
so this answers one of the questions i
got on the chat is what's what actually
is the dependency between multi-tape
turing machines and one tape turing
machines can we bound that in general
yes we can
we're going to show
that converting a multi-tape turing
machine to a one-tape turing machine can
at most blow up the amount of time
that's necessary by a squaring
um no i acknowledge it's a lot but it
still allows you um
uh but you know it's still small
compared with an exponential increase
and we're going to be focusing in this
course
on things like the difference between
polynomial and exponential not between
the different not not between the
difference uh of
n not between
not the difference between n squared and
n cubed that's going to be less of a
fact less of an issue from us
uh
okay
um
[Music]
so
the way i'm framing
uh
showing this theorem is that if you have
a multi-tape turing machine that can do
a language in a certain amount of time
then it's in the time complexity class
of that time bound squared
and the way i'm just saying that is
because this is the bound that's
utilizing the one tape model so another
way of saying that is converting
multi-tape to one tape
squares the amount of time you need at
most
so the way we're going to
prove that is
simply by going back and remembering the
conversion that we already presented
from multi-tape to one tape
and observe that if we analyze that
conversion it just uh ends up squaring
the amount of time that the multitape
used
okay so
why is that
so if you remember
let's just make sure we're all
altogether on this the way the single
tape machine s
simulates the multi-tape turing machine
m
is that it takes the contents of each of
m's tapes
you know up to the place where there's
infinitely many blanks obviously you
don't store the infinite part but the
the the the active portion of each of
them's tapes you're going to store them
consecutively in separate blocks on s's
tape on estes only tape
um and now every time m makes one move s
has to scan its entire tape to uh to uh
to
see what's under each of the heads and
to do all the updating
so to simulate one take step of m's
computation s is going to use order t of
n steps
where t of n is the total running time
that m is going to use so why is t of n
steps coming up here well that's because
you have to measure how s is going to
make a scan of course its tape
how big can its tape
be
well m
if it's trying to use as much tape as
possible
can use at most
t of n
um
tape on each of the t event cells on
each of its tapes so all together
there's just going to be some constant
number of times t of n cells on s's tape
do you see that
so each one of these is going to be at
most t of n long so this all together is
going to be order t of n log because you
know what can m do it could send its
head out
say the head on this tape here moving as
fast as possible to the right using as
much tape as it can but you can only use
t event cells in t of n time
so this is going to be ordered t of n
so one step of m's computation is going
to be t of n steps on s's computation
but m itself has t of n steps so it's
going to be t of n times t of n for the
total number of steps that s is going to
end up using
and that's where the squaring comes from
okay
similar results i'm not going to do lots
of simulations of one model by another i
think that you'll get the idea and you
can if you're interested you can uh
study those on your own but you can
convert multi-dimensional turing
machines to one one tape turing machines
um you know one tape ordinary uh
linear
one tape
one dimensional uh machines
and
the bottom line is that among all of the
reasonable models they're all what are
called polynomially related
uh if each can simulate the other with
at most the polynomial overhead
so if one of the machines can use this t
of n time the other machine that's
simulating it would use t to the k of n
time for some k
um that's what it means for the two
machines to be polynomially related and
all reasonable deterministic models are
polynomially related
so as we've already seen one tape in
multi-tape turing machines are
polynomial related because converting
multi-tape to one tape blows you up by
most squaring
so k equals two in this case
um multi-dimensional turing machines
again polynomial related
the random access machine which i'm not
going to define but it's the machine
that you might imagine you know you
would i'm sure they must define in some
form in the algorithms classes
polynomial related cellular automata
which are just arrays of a finite
automata that can communicate with each
other similar similarly
um
you know all the reasonable
deterministic models
um you know again classical models i'm
not talking about quantum computing
are polynomial polynomially related
so we are um
uh that kind of justifies our
uh choice in picking one of them as long
as we're going to ask questions which
don't depend upon the polynomial
so
let's then talk about the class p
so the class p this is an important
definition for us
this is um
the collection of all languages
that you can do
in time into the k
for some k
on a one take turing machine
or as i've written it over here i don't
know if this notation is
um unfamiliar to you but this is like
just a big sum
um but here it's a big union symbol
it's union over all values of k
of the time class n to the k
so this is
time n union to time n squared union
time n cubed union time into the fourth
and so on
um and we call these the polynomial time
decidable languages
okay so we're going to be spending um
you know uh a certain amount of effort
uh
exploring this class p and other similar
classes
somebody's asking why is it a union i'm
not sure how else you would write it so
if somebody hasn't if you have a
proposal for a different way to write it
that's fine but this is you know k this
is for all k
i don't know you know there's if you
only had a limit finite number of k's
you could just take the biggest one but
since it's for all k you need to write
it as a union
um
now i want to argue that the class p
um is an important class
and
you know why is it had so much impact on
the subject
um and in terms of applications as well
um
so one thing is that
the class p is invariant for all
reasonable deterministic models and what
do i mean by that
so we have defined the class p
in terms of these time classes here
which in turn are defined in terms of
the one tape model
so we have defined p by using one tape
turing machines
now if we had to find p
in terms of multi-tape turing machines
we get exactly the same class
because
one tape and multi-tape turing machines
are polynomially related to one another
and since we're
taking the union over all polynomials
that polynomial difference is going to
wash out
um
similarly we could define p
using any of the other reasonable
deterministic models we get exactly the
same class
so in a sense we get back what we um the
situation that we had in computability
theory when
the class of decidable languages
didn't depend on the choice of model
here the class p does not matter
depending upon the choice of reasonable
deterministic model
um
and we also kind of even in the case of
computability theory we have to stick
with kind of reasonable models that
cannot do an infinite amount of work in
one step
um
so
uh
you know when i'm not going to define
what it means to be reasonable and
that's in a sense an informal notion
but
among all of those reasonable models
you're going to get the same class p
the other thing that makes p important
is that
p roughly corresponds
to
the problems that you can solve in some
reasonable practical sense
not exactly you know problems that
require into the hundredth time
um you could argue
cannot be uh solved in any reasonable
sense um
but
uh you know if you think about it for
example from the perspective of
cryptography
um
uh cryptographic codes that people come
up with are typically designed to
require or or the hope is that they
require an exponential amount of effort
to crack if someone found even an into
the hundredth algorithm to crack uh
that would crack a code
people would feel that the code is not
secure even though into the hundredth is
still a large um
so you know it's a it's a rough kind of
test but it's still used as a kind of
litmus litmus test for practical
solvability if you can solve it in
polynomial time you basically figured
out how to avoid
um
large searches
if you can solve problems in in
polynomial time we'll say more about
that later
but you know
what i want to bring out here is that we
have combined here in the class p
something that's mathematically nice
mathematically element elegant with
something that's practically relevant
and when you have a combination of the
two then you know you have a winner then
you know how you have a concept that's
going to make a difference and that's
been true for the class b this has been
very influential
within and without
the theory of computation
um
so let's look at an example
um let's let's define a new language we
haven't seen before though it's similar
to
procedures that we've looked at before
the path language
which is where i'm going to give you a
graph g
two nodes in the graph s and t
um
where i'm thinking of g is a directed
graph so directed means that the um
the connections between the nodes in g
are going to be
redirected and that they have arrows on
them they're not just lines but they
have an orientation with an arrow
um
so g is a directed graph that has a path
from s to t that respects the directions
um so such a i think i might even have a
picture here yeah so imagine here here
is your graph if you can see it there
are little arrows connecting the uh the
nodes and i want to know is there a path
from the node s to the node t
so that is
you know a picture of a problem in you
know an instance of a graph of a path
problem
and i want to find uh an algorithm for
that and i can show that there is an
algorithm that operates in polynomial
time
for this uh path problem
okay and the algorithm uh you know any
of the standard
searching algorithms
uh would work here but let's just for
completeness sake um include the
breadth first search algorithm that we
have explored previously when we talked
about finite automata um so we'll mark s
and they'll keep repeating until nothing
new is new is marked and we'll mark all
of the nodes that were reachable
by a single arrow from a previously
marked node
um and then cft is marked
after you could mark everything you can
get to so you're going to mark
let's see pictorially i think i have
this in indicated yeah you're going to
mark all of the things that are
reachable from the start not from the
from the node s
and then see
after you can't mark anything new
whether the node is marked and if it is
you'll accept if it is not you reject
okay um
now we can analyze this too um and i'm
not going to be spending a lot of time
analyzing algorithms here um but let's
just uh do the do it kind of this one
time uh again
um
we're gonna we're get we're doing a
bunch of iterations here so gonna be
repeating until nothing new is marked so
each time we mark something new we can
only do that at most end times
at which point we've marked everything
so the number of iterations here is
going to be at most n
and now for each each time we've marked
something we have to
um
look at all of the previously marked
nodes
um and see which things they point at to
mark them too
so this is going to be an inner loop
which again has at most n iterations
because it's going to all of the
previously marked nodes and then once we
have
that we can scan g to see
to mark all of the
new
uh
all of the nodes which we have not yet
marked uh whether they're connected with
a previously marked node by an edge
and i'm being generous here because i
don't really care
um this can be done in the most n
squared steps on a one-take turing
machine i'm not going to describe the
implementation but you know i'll leave
it to you as an exercise but this is
straightforward
so the total number of steps here would
be n iterations times n iterations times
and squared so you're going to be at
most into the fourth steps needed so
this is a polynomial algorithm and
whether i ended up with n to the fourth
or n to the fifth or n cubed i don't
really care um because i'm just trying
to illustrate um that
the total is polynomial
and that's all i'm going to be typically
asking you to do um so to show
polynomial time what i'd be asking you
to do is to show that each stage
each stage of this algorithm
should be clearly polynomial
and that the total number of stages i'm
sorry this should say stages here should
be polynomial
so each stage is polynomial and after
you're doing all the iterations the
total number of stages that are executed
is polynomial and so therefore all
together the total running time the
total number of steps is going to be
polynomial
okay so that's um
the
uh the way
we would write up um polynomial
algorithms in this class um
so
let's see if there's any questions here
i don't want to
get too far ahead of people
um
let's see
um
yes in this theorem i'm talking about
one tape turing machines
um because we're defining everything in
terms of one type machines but now at
this point you know we're talking about
polynomial time we can you know my
analysis is based on one tape turning
machines
but in general you know you could use
any reasonable deterministic model on
which to carry out your analysis uh
because they're all polynomially
equivalent so from the perspective of
coming up with
showing that a problem is in polynomial
time isn't p
um you can use any of the models um
you know that you that you wish that for
convenient okay oh that's a good
question what is n thank you for asking
that question
n
is always going to be
reserved
to indicate the length of the input
so here
n
is going to be when we encode g s and t
and here also i haven't said this but
i'm assuming that
the encoding that you're using is also
somehow reasonable you know i think
we'll talk a little bit about more about
that in the next lecture um which is
going to be after the midterm
um
but you know you can
cause problems if you intentionally try
to come up with nasty encodings which
will you know
represent things uh
with unnecessarily many characters but
um
you know if if you try to be reasonable
then
um
you just use any one of those encodings
and you'll be fine
um so yeah
um so n is the length of the
representation of the input
um
let's see
someone's trying to you're trying to dig
into the my the actual how this is
running here scan g to mark all y where
x y is an edge
i'm saying that you can do an n squared
steps
um
uh
um
you know
if you have x
you can mark it in a certain place on
the tape
and then as you're going through every
other node every other edge um you can
you can go back and compare x with the x
of the edge
and then c
and then find the y
i mean it's just going to be too messy
to talk about here i mean i i'll leave
it this is an exercise to you i'm not
going to try to fumble my way through
explaining why you can do this in n
squared steps but it's it's not hard
um uh
you guys are all like
hardcore algorithms folks you want to
know the algorithms for this i'm not
going to do that sorry uh
high level picture here um
you know so so you know
if you want
you know if you want to look at
detailed analyses this is not the right
course for you um
can k equal n
what is k
um
um
[Music]
no
this if you're talking about this k here
k cannot equal n we're not looking at n
to the n um this is these are all fixed
k
um it's like n squared and q but not
into the end is going to be an
exponential bound and so that's not
going to be included within uh this
union
okay so we're near the end of the hour
um
i'm gonna
introduce one last language here
um called handpath
and the handpath problem
is um
i'm going to ask now again for a path
from s to t
but now a different kind of a path one
that goes through every node of g along
the way
um so i'm looking for a path that goes
that hits every note of g not just the
shortest most direct path but in a sense
the most indirect pair the longest path
that goes through from from s to t
that visits everything else along the
way um
a path that
of that kind that hits every node of the
graph is called the hamiltonian path
um
because the mathematician hamilton
studied um those made some definitions
about that i'm not gonna
i don't actually know the history there
but i just know they're called
hamiltonian pets
um
so here's a picture i want to get from
snt but i want to sort of pick up
everything else along the way
so as you remember the path problem
itself can be solved in p
and what i'd like to know
can the simple modification where i'm
asking you to visit everything else
along the way is that problem also in p
okay and i'm going to put it pose this
as a checking for you
um but actually before i get to that let
me give you an algorithm for handpath um
that doesn't work to show it's in p
um because it's exponential
so
here's an algorithm
for handpath
um
uh where let's m be the number of nodes
in g um
and what i'm going to do is i'm going to
try every can every
possible path in g
um and see if it's actually works as a
hamiltonian path
and except if it is
um
and then
if all paths fail uh then i'll reject
so i'm going to try every possible
routing through g if you want to think
about it
think of
m as every possible permutation of the
nodes of g and then you're going to see
whether that's actually constitutes a
path in g
um that takes you from s to t
and goes through all of the nodes um
so this algorithm would work
this would give you
a correct algorithm for the hand path
problem the problem is
the difficulty is that there are so many
possible paths that it's going to take
you an exponential number of steps to
execute this algorithm it's not a
polynomial time algorithm because there
are many possible pairs that you could
go through um if you're looking at you
know with a very crude bound but you
really can't improve that significantly
there would be um m-factorial which is
going to be
you know much greater than 2 to the m
paths of length m um so the algorithm is
going to run for exponential time and
not polynomial time
so my question for you is i'm going to
pose it as a check-in problem is whether
you could actually do this problem in
polynomial time
so why don't you think about that as i'm
setting up the question
so take the hand path problem
just like the path problem which i
described with that marking algorithm
but now you want to
hit every node along the way
can you show that problem is solvable in
p
and there's a whole range of
possibilities here where either the
answer is yes you can see what the
polynomial time algorithm is
uh
to
uh to definitely know where you can
prove there is no such polynomial time
algorithm
and i'll put this as a checking for you
and see i'm curious to see what you come
up with
most people are getting it wrong
well i mean wrong i don't you know i'm
not clear what wrong is here
um
okay are we done
please uh check something
you can see a few of you have not
answered but
the poll is running out
okay
time is up
um
so
uh in fact
you know as as i think many of you know
but not all of you uh this is an
unsolved problem this is a very famous
unsolved problem which is equivalent to
the p versus np problem that we're going
to be talking about very soon which
among other things would be worth a
million dollars if you solve it
so for those of you who have answered a
or e please talk to me after lecture um
and maybe we can work on it together
um
[Music]
uh no so
um
yeah i
i think most people would believe that
the answer is no um
uh but no one knows how to prove it at
this time uh so i'm interested in the
uh folks who have uh come up with uh
what they think are solutions um and i
should say that there are some folks who
um believe that there might be other
outcomes besides uh just a simple note
um
which might be proven eventually
um
so we're going to talk more about this
um but this is the answer to the
question just for your uh just to make
sure you understand is that it's an
unsolved problem right now so we don't
we don't know uh
definitely yes and definitely no at
least according to the state of
knowledge
of which i'm aware
is not um are not correct answers um but
any of the others
well who knows
um so
i think that's the end of what i had to
say for today
we covered complexity theory as an
introduction looked at different
possible models focused on the one tape
model
introduced based on the one tape model
these uh complexity classes the class p
and we
showed an example of this path problem
being in p
talked also about this hand path problem
which we'll talk about more um
after the midterm
okay so um i'll stick around for a few
minutes uh if you have any further
questions otherwise um
uh
okay so let me just take questions here
um
somebody's asking me about my personal
opinion on p versus np
um
my personal opinion on people versus np
is that p is not equal to np
and that we will prove it someday
when i was a graduate student back in
the mid 70s
i thought it would be solved by now and
in fact i made a bet
with len adelman
who i subsequently ended up becoming the
a of the rsa code
um that we would solve it by the year
2000 and i bet
what was then a lot of money for me
which was an ounce of gold
which i didn't end up then which i did
end up paying off to lend in the year
2000 so
i'm not making any more bets but i still
believe that it will be solved uh
hopefully i'll get a chance to see the
solution
um i've spent a lot of time thinking
about it myself
you know
obviously i haven't solved it otherwise
we would know but um
uh
you know uh hopefully somebody will
i'm getting asked a question here that's
kind of an interesting question but i
don't really know
um
i'm sure i understand it what's the
largest possible run time of a decidal
decidable problem
what is the larger largest decidable
runtime so you
anything that i can describe
can be um
there are going to be
algorithms
that run for longer
uh
you can
define
an algorithm you can define a runtime
which would in a sense
beats all other runtimes
which
so that anything any runtime is going to
be um
dominated by that
extremely slow runtime but it's not
something that one can describe
um i can describe it to you by perceive
mathematical procedure but there's it's
not going to be something like you know
uh
2 to the 2 to the n
somebody's here proposing
they prepare a solution to the hand path
problem
i presume in polynomial time
why is the following flawed if s goes
through all nodes and ends up at t
well s will not you mean you mean i
presume you mean starting at s if we end
up going through all nodes and
and end of t
um the proposal is a little complicated
here
basically you you want to if if i can
try to rephrase it you want to try to
from every possible node you want to try
to calculate a path to t
and also a path from s to that node um
and you can do that for all possible
nodes but there's no way to really
combine them into a single path
that visits all you know solving for
each node separately is not going to do
the trick
because you have to somehow combine all
that information into a single path
just one path that goes from s to t and
visits all the other nodes along the way
and that that is not uh
i i don't see how what your proposal um
how that's how that's going to actually
work
professor spitzer yes
um a question on
the um
like we were kind of talking about
earlier but like what we talked about
today was defined for the one tape turn
machines correct
yep
so um
and you said like we could have applied
for the multi multitape ones but um
are
like
is
well i don't know if it's we talked
about earlier but if something
is accepted by the one tape turn machine
like can be applied to the multi-tape
turn machine and vice versa like are
they interchangeable like that
well they're interchangeable only in the
sense that
the amount of time that you would need
it's a different machine if you have a
multi-tape turing machine for some
language
um you can convert it to a one-tape
turing machine using a procedure that we
described it earlier in the term
and she'll get a different machine it's
going to run for a different amount of
time
by using their procedure the point is is
that the amount of time that the
one-take turing machine is going to run
for is not that much
worse
than the multi-tape turing machine's
time so if the multi-tape turning
machine's time was
you know
uh end cubed
the one tape turning machines uh is
going to be the square of that so it's
going to be into the sixth okay but it's
not going to be it's not going from
multi-tape to one tape is not going to
convert you from polynomial to
exponential that's that's the only point
i'm trying to make it's going to convert
from one polynomial to a somewhat bigger
polynomial but it's still going to leave
you polynomial
[Music]
i don't know you don't seem to
i i can't see your face no no yeah i
guess i guess my opinion is that like
especially when we were talking about
earlier um when you're bringing it up it
just seemed like you could just turn
anything to a multi-tape turn machine
and like completely like cut the timeout
like if i had like something to n log n
like if i do it in a multi-tape turn
machine i have it in like
um like big o of n
yeah i mean
like it just seemed like the multi-tape
was so much more powerful but then
i guess
i guess not with the like with the
explanations and like the
the models we were talking about today
yeah i would not say the multi
multi-tape turing machines are still
pretty limited in their capabilities and
they're
um
you know don't forget when you have a
multi-tape turing machine you have only
a fixed number of tapes i mean you could
also define variations of multi-tape
turing machines that have increasing
number of tapes
as the input uh
you know under
you know either under program control it
can launch new tapes or it could um
um you know just have more tapes
depending upon the size of the input
that would also be a possibility that's
not the model that we have defined but
you could define a model like that
um
but as long as the total amount of work
being done by the machine at any step
it's going to be a polynomial amount of
work
um
then you can convert it to a one tape
turing machine uh with only a polynomial
increase in the bound all right so
you know you want to be careful of
machines you know you know one one thing
i meant to say but didn't say you know
so he would be an unreasonable model
um which you might think of as a
plausible model but it's not going to be
a reasonable model from our standpoint
and that would be a model um for example
that can do
um
full precision say integer
arithmetic um
uh
with a unit cost per operation so each
operation counts as a costs one
um
but i'm going to allow you to do for
example
you know addition and multiplication
uh the the thing that's bad about that
um in terms of being uh unreasonable
is that
uh
after k step each time you do a step
you could double the size of the integer
by by squaring it
yeah so after k steps you could have an
integer which is 2 to the k long
and now doing operations there is going
to involve an exponential amount of work
even in any reasonable sense
um you know in a theoretical sense and
also in a practical sense
so um
you know a model that operates like that
is not going to be able to convert to a
one-tape turing machine with only a
polynomial
increase because it's doing an
exponential amount of work potentially
you know uh within a polynomial number
of steps
um
so that's within a linear number of
steps within n steps
so that's um an example of an
uh
you know of an unreasonable
deterministic model yeah
thank you
sure
so i'm just curious some idea just
occurred to me um
i guess like if you had an oracle
turing machine uh basically just so that
you could look at a uh
a turing machine description and decide
whether it's a decider or not yeah um
then it'd be a little bit interesting to
think about uh
what happens if you look at
all uh you know if you have a
description of a pair of a turing
machine and an input string and you can
look at for all size n
descriptions of a pair uh like what's
the most steps that it takes
uh
for a such a machine
to converge
so then so then you'd have combined
turing machine and input stream
descriptions
uh where you can look at what's the
longest it takes to converge it's just i
don't know just a random thought that
occurred
yeah so we we actually we're gonna we we
will talk about oracle turing machines
uh later on in the term um
you know these are machines that have
access to sort of free information um
and that actually turns out to be uh
i mean
there's some interesting interesting
things you can say about what what
happens when you're providing a machine
with in a sense information for free
that
you know
you might otherwise want to charge it
for actually computing that information
but let's just say we're going to allow
it to
uh get that information without being
charged
and then how does that affect the
complexity of other problems for example
um
and so uh we will talk about that later
but
too much if i think of a digression at
this moment to try to define all that um
but happy to chat with you about it on
piazza if you if you want to raise a
question there i think
sure oh no problem
um so he's asking me about strategies
for solving the p versus np problem you
know we will talk also talk about that a
little later in the term as well
but
you know asking you know clearly
you know it seems beyond the reach of
our present techniques
to be able to prove that some problems
you know really take a long time like
the hamiltonian path problem seems like
you know there's nothing really you can
do that's significantly better than
trying all possibilities as i described
in that exponential algorithm you know
on the last slide uh but
um
how do you prove that nobody knows um so
um
lots of people have tried
including yours truly i mean i spent a
lot of time thinking about it having
succeeded with it but um
there is uh
um
you know
somebody i i think somebody someday
someday somebody will come up with the
the new idea that's needed to solve it
but it's going to clearly take some sort
of a breakthrough some sort of a new
idea it's not just going to be a
combination of existing ideas
the existing methods
um
i think we're about 10 minutes past a
few of you are still here i'm going to
say goodbye to you folks and um
um
shortly i'm going to join my tas for our
t weekly ta meeting so see you guys
thanks for being here